[موسيقى]
نرحب بمشاهدين مستمعي مونتي كارلو الدوليه
نرحب بضيوف البرنامج الذين تشاهدونهم على
الشاشه ويمكنكم ان تتفاعلوا مع ما يقولون
على صفحتنا على فيسبوك او على صفحه
البرنامج على تويتر
خطاب بوتين للامه كان حادا جدا حيال الغرب
حملت دول الغربيه بسبب دعمها الاوكرانيا
مسؤوليه الحرب متوعده بالاستمرار فيما
يسميه حتى الان عمليه عسكريه ذهب الى حد
الاعلان عن تعليق المشاركه في نيو ستارت
ما تسبب في ازعاج الامريكيين والناتو
وايضا العديد من الدول الاوروبيه الرئيس
بايدن رد طبعا من وارسو في كلمه اكد فيها
بان الغرب لا يخطط للتامر ضد روسيا ولكنه
قال ان روسيا لن تكسب ابدا الحرب في
اوكرانيا داعيا الى تقديم المزيد من الدعم
الى هذا البلد ما الذي ستفضي اليه حرب
الخطابات بين بوتين الى اي حد عدنا الى
عهد ما قبل الحرب البارده بين خروجشاف
وكينيدي سعيد بان يكون معي من موسكو
الكسندر وهو دبلوماسي روسي سابق سعيد بان
يكون معي من واشنطن سامح الهادي وهو عضو
في الحزب الديمقراطي وسعيد بان يكون معنا
من عمان عمر الرداد وهو خبير في الامن
الاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا بكم قبل ان نبدا
نضع المشاهدين في الصوره نستمع الى ما
قاله الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
المستحيل هزيمه روسيا
عسكريا ولذلك فهم
يقومون بهجمات في المجال الاعلامي وبوسة
الاجتماعي وهم يستهدفون الشباب
ونحن نراهم يحاولون ان يزيفوا الوقائع
التاريخيه ويستمرون في هجماتهم على
تاريخنا وعلى الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه الروسيه
ولكن ماذا يفعلون اذا شعوبهم
وبما اننا نتحدث عن حرب الخطابات مثل ما
جاء في العنوان نستمع كيف رد بايدن على
بوتين لقد قللوا من شان الامريكيين
والاوروبيين والعالم الحرم هذا العالم
الذي لا يسمح
لرجل يتسم بالجنون يستخدم القوى العنف ضد
الرئيس
ان الرئيس بوتين يواجهه شخصا لم يكن
يتوقعه وحاله لم يكن يتوقعها الديمقراطيات
هي اليوم اقوى
واستبداد
يتقلص بدل ان يتعزز
بوتر قال ايضا العقوبات الغربيه لم تؤثر
على موسكو لم يحصلوا على اي شيء عن طريق
العقوبات هؤلاء الذين بادروا بتلك
العقوبات انما يعاقبون انفسهم اليوم هذا
الامر افضى الى اغلاق المصانع ولديهم ازمه
في مجال الطاقه وشعبهم تقول هم يقولون
لشعوبهم بان هذا هو الذنب هو ذنب روسيا
فهذه العقوبات لم تؤثر
بنا
ولم تفضي الى
غياب المواد الاساسيه بشكل من الاشكال
من موسكو عدنا الى تاريخ كندي وخروج شيف
لا اعرف بالضبط
اظن انه الان شويه اسوا من من اللي كان
انا لا اقصد ثروه
الجزاع واللي كان خطر مباشر
للحرب النوويه في عهد خروج شوف
بل انا اقصد ما يجري الان
هذا
ازمه شامله
ازمه التي
تشمل كافه المجلات
ومواجهه ليست موجهه سريعه وممكن
انهاءها من خلال قرار
رئيسين
لانه ازمه طويله نتيجه
الاسماء
ستقوم
سيكون تشكيل نظام
جديد نظام العلاقات الدوليه
فبالتالي
ما ينشر الان انا لا اظن ان هذا تبادل
بخطابات مع بين الرئيس بوتين والرئيس
بايدن
الرسائل
ليست موجهه من بوتين الى بايدن لا وليس
لا توجه بهم بوتين الى حكام الغرب لا ربما
الى الراي العام
الدولي ولكن
اكثر شيء موجهه داخل روسيا الى المجتمع
الروسي
وانا لا افتقد ان يكون
حل او تحويل الوضع من
الخالي نحو الاقصى
بقرار
لطرف ما ازمه سوف تستمر طيب
سمح الهادي وكاننا امام العصا والجزره
يعني الجزره عندما يقول بايدن نحن لا نخطط
للتامر ضد روسيا ومن جهه اخرى يقول روسيا
لن تكسب ابدا الحرب في اوكرانيا وسنستمر
في تقديم هذا الدعم الى اوكرانيا وبوتينا
اعتقد انه قوي ولكنه اصطدم بالاراده
الحديديه للولايات المتحده والاخر
كان سبق ونتحدث اذا هي حرب خطابات القصد
كل طرف يضغط على الاخر
في البدايه تحت استاذ توفيق وللساده
المشاهدين وكذا الضيوف المشاركين معنا لا
يمكن ابدا النظر الى خطاب الرئيس بايدن
بمعزل عن الاطار الزمني والاطار الاجتماعي
والتاريخي الذي وقع فيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
ذهبت في زياره غير معلنه لرئيسها في
الاسبوع الذي تكمل فيه العمليه العسكريه
كما سميها روسيا وهي عدوان مفتوح على
اوكرانيا عامها الاول وذهبت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لتؤكد ليس فقط مجرد
وجودها على الصف الاول ولكن قيادتها لهذا
التحالف العالمي الذي وضع فيه الرئيس
بايدن في كلمته في بولندا
[موسيقى]
الى اين تريد الولايات المتحده ان تصل من
هذا الخطاب والى اي مدى يمكن ان نستمر
دعمها في رايي ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تريد ان تصل الى حدود جديده
لسياسه الروسيه
ولتوسعاتها والاحلامها الامبراطوريه
القديمه التي يحاول الرئيس بوتين بعثها من
جديد وفي المدى العالمي تريد الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه التاكيد على انها
لازالت اللاعب رقم واحد في سياسه الخارجيه
العالميه وان تحالفها مع اوروبا تحالف
اصيل وازداد قوه ولا اي محاوله بوضع هذا
التحالف او القوه العسكريه والاقتصاديه
لكل من الولايات المتحده والناتو على جانب
هامشي والتغافل والتصرف بعيدا عن اثرها
على الساحه العالميه لان يكون ابدا مقبولا
ولن يكون سهلا على الاقل في المدى المنظور
طيب عمر الرداد كخبير في الامن
الاستراتيجي الان الصدام حسب رايك حتمي ام
لا ام يمكن تجنبه
الو هل تسمعني
تسمعني ام لا
طيب يبدو ان منذ البدايه فقد الصوت
ربنا يستر اعود اليك يا ضيفي من موسكو
يعني عندما يبدا الرئيس الامريكي
هذا الكلام ويصف بوتين بالجنون
ويتحدث بهذه الطريقه هل تعتقد انه سيبقى
مجال للحوار بين الرجلين
انا استبعد الحوار واظن وما فيش تفاوض
روسي مع هذه الاداره
وثيقه مفقوده
اطلاقا
بوتين
لاجئه الى
مصطلحات عده قال انه يكذبون ويخدعون وائل
اخره
ليس فقط بهدف عنه
نقض للموقف الغربي بل هذا اكثر من ذلك انه
ما فيش مجال للحديث مع هؤلاء الذين
مثلا
تم التوقيع الموحده يتراجعون في ايه عن
هذا وبلالي
اتفاقيه مثلا
وبالنسبه للشرعيه دوليه لامريكان خرجوا من
عده المعاهدات والى اخره يعني طيب طيب
اعتقد انك تسمعني الان من عمان تسمعني
الان
نعم نعم من خلال متابعتك للخطبين خطاب
الرئيس الروسي الذي كان حادا اللهجه وخطاب
الرئيس الامريكي هل تعتقد ان الصدام سيكون
حتميا وان وقود هذه الاصطدام ستكون
اوكرانيا
مساء الخير لك ولضيفيك الكريمين والاخوه
المشاهدين اعتقد
الخطابين
خطاب الرئيس بوتين والرئيس بايدن يقعان في
حقل تقييم سنه بعد مرور سنه على هذه الحرب
ودخولنا بالسنه الثانيه بمعنى ان الخطابين
تضمناه تقييما لفتره سنه مرت على هذه
الحرب وماذا تحقق بالنسبه لروسيا وفق
اهدافها المعلنه وكذلك بالنسبه للرئيس
الامريكي وبوصف واشنطن هي قائده لحلف شمال
الاطلسي وهي التي تقود هذه الحرب بشكل غير
مباشر عبر الدعم العسكري اعتقد ان كل طرف
في خطاباته اراد توجيه رسائل محدده للراي
العام
وللطرف الاخر بالوقت نفسه
فرسائل الرئيس بوتين كانت تؤكد على انتصار
روسيا وقدم ايضا ما يمكن وصفه بين قوسين
بتبريرات لخوض هذه الحرب وانها مرتبطه
بافق وابعاد خارج مساحه اوكرانيا وهذه
الحرب التي تجري اليوم او وفقا للتعبير
الروسي للعملي العسكريه وايضا الرئيس من
جانبه الرئيس الامريكي بايدن اراد تاكيد
فشل الرهانات الروسيه بهذه الحرب ان على
صعيد
تفكك الاتحاد الاوروبي ونرى اليوم كيف
تدخل دول من اوروبا الشرقيه في منطقه
اليورو وبالاتحاد الاوروبي وعلى صعيد حتى
استخدام ملف الطاقه
ايضا على صعيد الرهانات على التفرق وتفكيك
حلف
وبالفعل انا لدي قناعه كمتابع ان اوروبا
يجب ان نتذكر كيف كان الاتحاد الاوروبي لا
اقول قاب قوسين او ادنى من الانهيار قبل
24 فبراير العام الماضي لكنه كان يواجه
مشاكل حاده وكذلك نتذكر برئاسه الرئيس
عنده في الحقبه التي تولى فيها الرئيس
ترامب رئاسه الولايات المتحده كيف جرى
الخلاف مع الاوروبيين وبشكل حاد حول
عمليات تمويل لحلف الاطلسي ومساهمات
اوروبا ومساهمات الولايات المتحده
وكانت تطرح اسئله كبيره من نوع ما قيمه
وما جدوى وما هي مبررات وجود اتحاد بهذا
الشكل اليوم اذا ما ذهبنا الى تقييم السنه
الاولى من هذه الحرب نجد اوروبا اكثر
تماسكا واصبحت وحده اقتصاديه
رهانات الرئيس والقياد الروسيه على موضوع
النفط وان الشعوب الاوروبيه ستموت وستتجمد
من البرد يبدو ان على مشارف اسابيع وينتهي
الشتاء ولم تحدث ثورات ويبدو ان الحديث عن
ملف التدفئه قد انتهى الى حد كبير في
اوروبا ايضا القوه العالميه اليوم يتطلع
الرئيس بوتين والى حد كبير معه الصين
لتشكيل نظام عالمي جديد لعل السؤال
المطروح اليوم
انه اذا الوزن النسبي للقوه العسكريه في
تشكيل هذا النظام
العالم الجديد اليوم الرئيس بوتين اشار
الى ان فرنسا والمانيا تذهب باتجاه اعداد
وانتاج وتطوير اسلحه نوويه وانه وان روسيا
لن تسكت عن ذلك بمعنى اننا امام قوه
اوروبيه جديده اعلن عنها الرئيس ماكرون
واعلن عنها
المستشار الالماني
النصوص مخصصات الدفاع وهنا قوه جديده اخرى
ايضا جنوب شرق اسيا بقياده اليابان بمعنى
اننا امام تشكل نظام عالمي جديد هذا
النظام العالمي الجديد اليوم
يلغي بالكامل اتفاقات والحدود التي رسمتها
دبابات الحرب العالميه الثانيه بتقسيم
برلين وغيرها وتبدو معها وفقا للرؤيه
الامريكيه على الاقل والغربيه ان روسيا
قوه اقليميه وليست قوه دوليه كما يتم
الحديث عنه نعم طيب ضيفي في موسكو كيف
تتفاعل ما يقوله من ردد
الانتقال الى
نظام على مين جديد هذا فكره معجون اصبحت
مشتركه ولكن كل واحد يقصد شيء فيه فيها
والامريكان يريدون الحفاظ على الهيمنه
وحتى على حساب اوروبا
الروسيه هي تريد المساواه في الحقوق
للجميع المشاركين يعني
فيعتبر ان هذا الموقف متجاوب مع الروخباث
الاكثريه الدول العالم ولو
عدد كبير منها مصره الان
يسمع الراعي اولا الراعي الامريكي ولكن
نتيجه لما يحدث يكون هناك
التغييرات الجزري يا في العلاقات في نفس
الوقت حتى هذا القرار الاخير لرئيس بوتين
هو لا يعني انه روسيا تسعى الى توتير
الاجواء بالعكس انه
الحفاظ على توازن هذا هو
هدف لكل تصرفات الروسيه لانه في اوكرانيا
هذا ينهار حرف التي استمرت ثمانيه سنوات
والله وقت تمدد الناتو والان بنزبط
للاسلحه الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه الهجوميه
هذا ايضا
الرؤيه للمرحله القادمه
ومحاولات لصنع الانواع الجديده
لهذه الاسئله وايضا
الاعتبار القدرات المشتركه الغربيه الله
في اطار الناطولي ليس فقط الامريكيه فلذلك
روسيا لديها رؤيه
سامح الهادي الا توجد مؤشرات بان الوضع قد
ينزلق باتجاه لا تحمد عقبه عندما نرى
المذكره التي سلمتها الدبلوماسيه الروسيه
الى السفيره الامريكيه في موسكو هذا
الانذار لابد من سحب الجنود الامريكيين
والمعدات العسكريه الامريكيه ومعدات
الناتو في اقرب وقت من اوكرانيا
يعني ساجيب على هذا السؤال ولكني يعني لا
اتفق مع الضيف من موسكو عندما قال ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تريد تعزيزها
هيملتها فيما يبدو انه تشكل لنظام عالمي
جديد ولو حتى على حساب اوروبا فالولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اعطت اولويه دائمه
لتحالفاتها الوثيقه مع اوروبا منذ العمل
1945 بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه والفتره
الوحيده التي شهدت اضطرابا بسبب يعني قرار
منفرد وسياسه منفرد لا تاخذ باعتبارها
ابدا
المصالح العليا للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في استقرار لهذا التحالف كانت
الفتره التي تولى فيها الرئيس ترامبو الذي
ورد الى البيت الابيض من خارج النظام
الاداري والسياسي
والاجتماعي للمؤسسه الدوله العميقه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اما عن ناحيه
انزلاق الامر الى مواجهه مباشره مفتوحه مع
روسيا من خلال الامريكيه او من خلال الحلم
في الناتو لا اعتقد ان هذا الامر مهما بدت
لنا مؤشرات على الارض تريد يعني تؤكد او
تشير الى حتميه حدوثه فكل الاطراف بما
فيها روسيا لا تريد ابدا ان تدخل في
مواجهه مفتوحه مع كل العناصر العسكريه
لانه بحسابات القوى لن يكون هناك فائز
ولكن بالحسابات الرقميه لهذه القوه
فالولايات المتحده الامريكيه وحلف الناتهم
اقوى من روسيا بشكل مؤكد وليس ابدا هناك
يعني انسان عاقل صاحب قرار استراتيجي
يستطيع ان يتخذ قرارا بغزو دوله نوويه
سواء كانت ان تغزى روسيا بفعل قوات من
الناتو او ان تقوم روسيا بغزو دوله حليفه
في الناتو لان كلاهما يعلم تماما انه في
هذه المرحله لنكون هناك حسابات لاي شيء
وان الكل سيكون خاسر بشكل كبير السؤال
الذي لا يزال مطروحا بقوه الى اي مدى يمكن
ان نصل الى التصعيد وان نصل الى ما يعرف
بسياسه حافه الهاويه حتى نجلس على مائده
المفاوضات الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واوروبا وحلف الناتو يبدو انهم عازمون على
استمرار دعمهم لاوكرانيا ليس لتحقيق النصر
فلن يتقبل يعني الروس هزيمتهم بشكل مخزن
في اوكرانيا وليس هناك مصلحه للنظام
العالمي في هزيمه منكره كاسره لروسيا ولكن
في نفس الوقت لن يكون هناك ايضا محو
لاوكرانيا والوجودها وسيادتها ووحده
وسلامه اراضيها الامراض سيرسلان الى نقطه
التعادل المؤلمه في لحظه ما تجبر كل
الاطراف على الجلوس على مائده المفاوضات
وتقديم تسويات مؤلمه لان استمرار هذه
الحرب لن يكون مفيدا لاحد ولكن من الذي
يملك النفس الاطول من هو القادر على ان
يحشد ويضع استراتيجيات متوسطه وطويله
الامد على المستوى الاقتصادي والعسكري
والسياسي ويبدو حتى هذه اللحظه عند
الولايات المتحده نجحت ذلك بدعم غربي كبير
اذا ما اخذنا في الاعتبار ان الولايات
المتحده دعمت بدائل الطاقه لاوروبا اوروبا
كانت اسيره لنظام الطاقه الروسي وتخلت عنه
وتخلصت منه بشكل يعني يثير الاعجاب
الاقتصاد الروسي رغم ادعاءات الرئيس بوتين
يعاني من تبعات العقوبات واثرها يزداد
حضورا في الاقتصاد الروسي مع الايام ولا
يزال الدعم العسكري الذي راهن بوتين
ونظامه كريميلين على انه سيتوقف في لحظه
ما تحت ضغوطات الاضطرابات الاجتماعيه
المتاثره بارتداد العقوبات سواء كانت في
اوروبا او في امريكا او حتى في دول اخرى
كل هذه الرهانات للاسف الشديد من وجهه
نظره لن تحقق له النتائج التي يرجوها عمر
الرداد يعني عندما نسمع يقول صراحه ان
التفاوض مع بوتين مضي على الوقت في ردا
على تصريحات للرئيس ماكرون يعني الان
خرجنا من هذا المنطق عندما نسمع
الدبلوماسي من موسكو يتحدث عن احتمال
الدخول في مفاوضات يعني هذا عفوا ضيف من
من واشنطن هل الامور اصبحت صعبه الان
نعم الحقيقه واضح من خلال خطابات اليوم ان
موضوع المفاوضات لن يحدث بالمدى المنظور
الا اذا كان هناك معجزات حقيقيه وهذا غير
وارد على الاقل في خلال عام 2023
الجاري الا اذا جرت تطورات حقيقيه على
الارض بالنسبه للمعارك وحسمها بين
الجانبين يبدو قضيه المفاوضات اليوم تقدم
من كل طرف من الطرفين الروسي والاوكراني
كل طرف يقدم نفسه باتجاه انه هو الذي يريد
السلام ويريد التفاوض والجلوس مع الطرف
الاخر وان الطرف الاخر لا يريد لاسباب
مختلفه روسيا حقيقه اذا ما عدنا الى
الوراء قليلا وعلى لسان الرئيس بوتين وضعت
شروطا
تنتمي الى مصطلحات وقاموس الحرب العالم
الثانيه وهذا غير قائم في الحروب الحديثه
مطلقا بمعنى انها تريد الاستسلام وربما
تغيير القياده
وضمانات بنزع السلاح من اوكرانيا ايضا
اتهامات التي تتوجه للرئيس زيلينسكي بانه
فاقد للقدره على اتخاذ القرار وانه مجرد
العوبه بيد الغرب واعتقد ان كل هذا قابل
للتمحيص والفحص في ضوء صمود الاوكرانيين
اليوم يبدو ان الرئيس
زيلينسكي ليس وحده او ليس وحده والمحيط به
هو الذي يقاتل في اوكرانيا بل هناك نسبه
كبيره من الشعب الاوكراني تدافع عن بلدها
وهو مكان دافعا لدى الغرب لتزويدهم
بالاسلحه وشكل المفاجاه وان الاوكرانيين
قادرين قادرون على الصمود لا اعتقد ان
مفاوضات قريب اليوم
اذكر ان الرئيس زليكي قال سابقا في تماهي
مع الخطاب الغربي بان المفاوضات لن تكون
بوجود الرئيس بوتين بمعنى ان ربما تكون
هناك مفاوضات ولكن
بقياده روسيه جديده على ايه حال اجمالا
استاذ توفيق اجابه على تساؤلك بخصوص
المفاوضات والنقد
وملاحظاته على
ما يقوله الرئيس ماكرون يجب ان نعترف بان
هناك موقفا اوروبيا تقوده المانيا وفرنسا
لازال يصر رغم موقفه الواقعي في اطار
قانون الوحده والصراع مع الولايات المتحده
بمعنى الوحده ضد الجيش الروسي وضد اجراءات
بوتين وغزو اوكرانيا
وتزويد اوكرانيا اسلحه لكن هذا لا ينفي
محطات خلاف بين بين الجانبين هذا الموقف
الالماني الفرنسي
وارتباطا بالجغرافيا السياسيه لازال يفتح
نافذه محدده للرئيس بوتين باتجاه استمرار
الحوار معه مره اخرى المفاوضات واضح جدا
انها ليست بالمدى المنظور في اطار
استراتيجيه الطرفين الثابته تجاه الحرب
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه تقوم على استسلام
اوكرانيا واعترافها بالقلم جزء من روسيا
والاعتراف بالجمهوريات الانفصاليه ايضا
جزء من الاتحاد الروسي وهذا لا اعتقد ان
اوكرانيا ستقبل به ايضا مطالب اوكرانيا
المتضمنه بدعم غربي اليوم ليس الانسحاب من
الجمهوريات فقط التي يعني ليس الانسحاب من
الواقع الذي ترتب بعد 24 فبراير الماضي بل
ان الناتو اليوم
يلمح ويعلن بانه المطلوب الانسحاب من
القرب واستعاده شبه جزيره القرم بمعنى انه
الفجوه لا زالت بعيده ويبدو ان روسيا لم
تلحق بها الخسائر الكافيه التي تجبر
القياده الروسيه على الجلوس على طاوله
المفاوضات كما انه اوكرانيا في ظل هذا
الدعم الغربي
والمفرط والذي قد يصل الى طائرات الاف 16
وغيرها تبعا لتطورات الحرب
هذا القياده الاوكرانيه اليوم ترى نفسها
في موقف جيد وقادره على الصمود وقادر على
احباط مخططات روسيا نعم ضيفه من موسكو
عندما تسمع هذا الكلام لنعود الى مضمون
طبعا الى الخطابين عندما يتحدث بادا بهذه
الطريقه يقول دكتاتور عازم على اعاده بناء
امبراطوريه لا يمكن له ابدا ان يؤثر على
حب شعب للحريه ان العنف لن يسحق ابدا
اراده الذين يريدون ان يبقوا احرارا يعني
الكلام واضح هل تستشف في هذا الكلام نوع
من الرساله المبطنه باننا مهما تقول سنظل
الى جانب الاوكرانيين عسكريا
صحيح انه هنا نرى تناقض في
مواقف وخطه في المفاهيم لانه
رؤيا روسيه لما يهدوس
تختلف تماما عن ليس فقط عن رؤيه امريكا
بل ربما اجمالا
الروي الغربيه
والموضوع يعود
ربما الى محاولات قياده كتابه تاريخ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
في ضوء في العالم الغربي عندما يطعمون
يتهمون في ان واحد هتلر
وخطاب موضوع هتلر تراجع او ما فيش اهميه
اما الموضوع ستايل فهو موجود وبالتالي
موضوع
بالتالي موضوع موضوع الروسيه وهنا في
القصه ايضا التزوير الله كانه بوتين يريد
استعاده الاتحاد السوفيتي
والاثمان الامبراطوريه ووائل اخره
في روسيا
تصور اخر تماما
انه
الغرب يعود الى نوعا ما فكره الفاشيه
والفكره الفرشيه
تجسدت في اوكرانيا والعالم الغربي يؤيد
اوكرانيا
الى الله تصادم بين اوكرانيا
وروسيا لضعف روسيا استنزاف روسيه واوائل
اخره فبالتالي
الحاسم العسكري حسب تصور الروسي هذا
انتصار روسيا على نظام الماجي في اوكرانيا
هذا هو ليس موضوع الاستسلام ولا تغيير
الطبيعه النظام
المسيطر اليوم في اوكرانيا وليس موضوع
رئيس جيليسكي
او اشخاص هذا موضوع
الاوكرانيه المسيطره اليوم في هذا البلد
والغرب يؤيد بشكل كامل
هذه هذه الرديكاليه
فالله ما فيش مخرج الا كما اعلن بوتين
القضاء على الناجيه في اوكرانيا هذا هو
الهدف الاساسي
للجهود الروسيه
الاول والى اليوم
فالرغم انه
روسيا قالت رسميا جاهزين لتفاوض ولكن
عمليا
يبدو غير وارد ما بين روسيا وهذا النظام
الموجود في كيف والذي الله منذ سنه 14 طيب
سامح الهادي هناك انطباع بانه حوار طرشان
بين موسكو و واشنطن
يعني يعتقد انه حوار طرشان على المستوى
الرسمي المعلن ولكن على مستوى القنوات
الدبلوماسيه والامنيه والاستخباراتيه
الحوار لم ينقطع للحظه واحده وشاهدنا
اعلانا في وقت متاخر بعد حدوثها عن
مكالمات هاتفيه بين رئيس الاركان في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ورئيس الاركان
الروسي ووزير الدفاع شيكوب الروسيه ايضا
فلا يمكن ابدا فصل القنوات السريه لانها
هي المفتاح الاستمراري محبس الاماني ومنع
الانزلاق حوادث ياسف لها الجميع حين لا
ينفع للاسف ولا الندم وهذا لا يعتقد انه
ابدا
سهلا لابلاغ
الابلاغ الروس بان بايدن يتجه نحو كيف على
سبيل المثال
قبل وصول طائره الرئيس بايدن الى بولندا
في وقت يعني حساس وتدرك روسيا ايضا اهميه
استمرار هذه الاتصالات روسيا تعلم تماما
انها رغم رغبتها اشار الضيف الى اهداف
بعيده الامد بدات بها العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا لتغيير النظام ومحاربه النازيه
والفاشيه الجديده والنظام الريديكالي وهذا
هو الخطاب الذي يسوقه النظام الروسي
للداخل الروسي الذي يشهد بين فتره واخرى
مجموعه من المظاهرات وان كانت قليله وذلك
بسبب القمع الامني لانتفاضه ورغبه في ان
تعلن عدم رضاها عن ما يتعرض له الشعب
الاوكراني الذي تربطه بالروس يعني روابط
اجتماعيه واسريه قديمه لا ينكرها الا جاهل
ولكن استمرار هذا الخطاب الان بعد مرور
عام سيجعل الامر اكثر صعوبه وهذا ما دعى
الرئيس بوتين بنفسه لان يخرج على الشعب
الروسي ويؤكد في خطابه الذي كان يستهدف
الشعب والراي العام الروسي اكثر من اي طرف
اخر ان هناك رغبه في استمرار هذه الحرب
لانها حرب وجوديه وان روسيا اضطرت الى هذه
الحرب فعل تجاهل الغرب وتجاهل الناتو لما
يحفظ روسيا وهذا امر مردود عليه ببساطه من
ذا الذي يستطيع ان يهدد امن اكبر قوه
نوويه في العالم بخمسه الافراس ليس لاحد
ابدا مصلحه في ان يحدث ذلك ولكن استعاده
الامجاد الامبراطوريه القديمه حتى على
انقاذ اوكرانيا التي كانت باعثه تاريخيه
للنهضه الروسيه هذا والهدف الذي يسعى اليه
بوتين ليحقق مجدا شخصيا يربطه ببطرس
التاسع الذي كان عفوا ببطرس الرابع الذي
كان هو باعثا لروسيا الحديثه كل هذه
الامور تختلط في الذهن الروسي ويراها
الغرب ويراها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
امور يجب الوقوف والتصدي لها باي شكل من
الاشكال وهذا هو ما دعا الى ضروره التدرج
والتنوع في السلاح الذي يقدم من ناحيه
طبيعته العسكريه لاوكرانيا بدانا باسلحه
متوسطه المدينه باسلحه خفيفه بمساعدات
المتوسطه ووصلنا الان كما قلت في هذه
الحلقه الى الحديث عن الطائرات الاكس
162 مليار دولار الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قدمتها بشكل مساعدات عسكريه
وانسانيه واقتصاديه لاوكرانيا هذا ينعكس
شيئا يعكس شيئا واحدا فقط ان قبول
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بفرض النظام
العالمي الجديد بالقوه العسكريه عليها
وعلى حلفائها في تغيير لقواعد اللعبه
الديمقراطيه وسياده القانون لن يكون
مقبولا في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه طيب
عمر الرداد الى اي حد هذا النزاع اعاد
التبعيه من قبل اوروبا الى الولايات
المتحده
ليست هناك
اعرف ولكن هو تحالف هناك من يصفها
بالتبعيه هناك مقالات كتبت عن هذا الموضوع
الى اي حد هذا النزاع اذا استمرت سيزيد
سيزيد من فكره بان التبعيه تبعيه اوروبا
للولايات المتحده عادت من جديد
نعم بالمدى المنظور اعتقد انه ثبت
منذ سقوط الاتحاد السوفياتي وتفكيك عام
1990 وحتى الغزو الروسي او العملي الخاصه
الروسيه كما يحب الروس ان يسموها
لاوكرانيا
اعتقد
تراخت اوروبا
واقتنعت على مدى 30 عاما بامكانيه السلام
وانه يجب ان توجه
مقدراتها والتنميه للشعوب وللاستثمار
الاقتصادي وفي ظل العولمه نعرف الشركات
الاقتصاديه الكبرى العابره للقارات وذهبت
بهذا الاتجاه لكن
فاجاتها الحرب ووجدت نفسها من ناحيه
عسكريه غير قادره الى حد كبير لوحدها على
مواجهه
الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا واذا ما تجاوز هذا
الدخول الروسي الجيش الروسي اذا ما كان
كما يتردد في الاعلام الغربي على النموذج
الهتلالي وان يصل الى وارسو الى بولندا
والى غيرها من الدول وحتى يهدد المانيا
وفرنسا لكن على المدى البعيد اعتقد جازما
اننا خلال سنوات قليله قادمه سنجد كما قال
الرئيس بوتين اليوم حول النووي
البرامج الاسلحه النوويه في المانيا وفي
فرنسا سنجد كتله اوروبيه
وعسكريه واقتصاديه
عالميه منافسه ضمن الكتل الرئيسيه هذه
الكتله ستقودها المانيا بالدرجه الاولى
وفرنسا وايطاليا والى حد كبير جدا اسبانيا
هذه الدول ذات المداخيل العاليه التي
اليوم ادركت انه لابد من اعاده بناء
طرسانتها عسكريه حتى لو
ذهبت القياده الروسي الحالي ولو جرى
السلام اعتقد انها ستمضي قدما في برامجها
عفوا
باتجاه المزيد من التسليح والاسلحه
الدفاعيه لسبب بسيط انه لم يعد مضمونا
اليوم ان تاتي قياد روسيه بعد عشره او
خمسه عشر سنه في روسيا
وتهدد احدى دول البلطيق على سبيل المثال
او ترسل جيوشها واسلحتها الى حدود الاتحاد
الاوروبي وتحديدا اتحدث عن الدول
الاوروبيه الغربيه لكن هذا التموضع او هذا
السيناريو بظهور قوه اوروبيه
نرى مؤشرات اليوم عبر زياده موازنات
الدفاع في روسيا والمانيا وايطاليا وحتى
في اسبانيا هذا على الصعيد الاوروبي لكن
ايضا هناك كتل اعتقد ان النظام العالمي
الجديد الذي يطالب به الرئيس بوتين يتم
تشكيله الان شيئا فشيئا وهو بدا يتموضع
عبر ما تحدثت باوروبا التي ستكون مقابل
روسيا مدعومه من الولايات المتحده ومن
بريطانيا ومن كندا واستراليا وهذا سيكون
ايضا حلف اخر اعتقد
نذهب الى جنوب شرق اسيا اليابان اليوم
وهذا كما قلت في مداخله الاولى يتم اليوم
تغيير عالميا
لمغادره مربعات التي رسمتها الدبابات بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه حتى هذه التغييرات
من المؤكد ستطال مجلس الامن وتركيبه مجلس
الامن مشكله روسيا اليوم انها لديها قناعه
ان القوه العسكريه الجباره بما فيها القوه
الن هي المحدد عمليا وعلى ارض الواقع وفي
التاريخ الحديث القوه العسكريه وحدها لا
تكفي اليوم اذا ذهبنا الى الوضع الاقتصادي
العقوبات الدول الملتزمه بالعقوبات
الاقتصاديه على روسيا مجموع دخله 51
التريليون دولار بالمقابل روسيا واحد ونصف
مليون واحد ونصف التريليون دولار الرئيس
الروسي عندما يتحدث عن ضروره التضييق على
الدولار واستبداله بالروبل وبالعملات
الاخرى يتحدث بالمخرجات عن المجاميع
بالدولار هذا يعني شيء ملفت للنظر ويبدو
ان انفكاك او الاطاحه بسيطره الولايات
المتحده كقوه عالميه جباره
على العالم اليوم يعني اصبح موضع لازال
موضع تساؤلات في ظل القوه الاقتصاديه
والعسكريه للولايات المتحده واعتقد ان
الولايات المتحده نفسها تعبت من دور
الشرطه العالم هي تريد اوروبا قادره على
الدفاع عن نفسها تنافسها اقتصاديا وتقدم
لها الدعم وكذلك في شرق اسيا تريد اليابان
وتريد الهند وتريد استراليا بمواجهه الصين
ومعهما بمعنى ان هذه التكتلات الجديده
اليوم التي لا يؤخذ بها المعيار العسكري
معيارا وحيدا لان المعيار العسكري فقط
يحول الدول يتم شيطنتها يعني تصبح انت
لديك صواريخ عابره للقارات وصواريخ فرط
صوتيه ولديك نووي ماذا ستختلف روسيا
المستقبل عن كوريا الشماليه اليوم او عن
ايران روسيا تستحق افضل من ذلك بكثير
واستغرب بالختام حتى اللحظه انه لم يطرح
باطار النخب الروسيه مساله الحل باوكرانيا
ان تكون فيدراليه روسيا ذاتها فيدراليه
فيها شعوب تتحدث لغات مختلفه
باديان مختلفه ربما ساجيبك الضيف لماذا لا
يطبق لماذا لا يطبق هذا في اوكرانيا اعتقد
انه حل وسط بالنسبه للغرب وبالنسبه لروسيا
[موسيقى]
وفي اشياء كثيره
والله مش مضبوطه على الاطلاق شيء الاخير
انه في اوكرانيا هذا
السنوات كانت روسيا تدعو الى
فيدراليه في اوكرانيا
واتخاذ القرار عن صفه خاصه
لدنباص
والعطاء
نظام كيف والله خرفه اللي رفضوا كل ذلك
الله
يعني سلاح ماوى والهذا
روسيه دائما كانت طويله
التوازن ما بين
كل القوى وعدم توازن وين هذا بتمدد
اذا كان امريكا تريد
القوى
المستقل في اوروبا او صين او شيف نحن نرحب
بذلك ولكن غير صحيحه على الاطلاق
هذا مش مش مضبوطه هذا الله
نحن ما نريده اوكرانيا ليكون بالغ خيالي
ولا يتكون خطرا
لروسيا هذا هو هدف الروسي
والاتخاد السوفيتي الذي انتصر في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وانقذ العالم واليوم
خاكيك
امبراطوريه روسيه وشيسيه والى اخره
جدير بالذكر نحن لم نحترم ابدا الخديصا
الديمقرا طيه الامريكيه هذا كذب ما فيش
ديمقراطيه في امريكا
سنفتح نقاشيه مستقبلا لان دائما
في الحزب الديمقراطي ومن عمان عمر رداد
خبير في الامن الاستراتيجيه شكرا لفريق
البرنامج امسيه مريحه للجميع
[موسيقى]